President Trump this morning chose to
retweet a fox news story on us
satellites that according to these
sources stay detected North Korean
anti-ship cruise missiles now notably we
don't have that reporting it's also
notable that this report contained
classified information two unnamed
sources of course the president has
railed against unnamed sources just
hours later UN Ambassador nikki Haley
was asked about that report on Fox did
the president retweeted here's what she
said I can't talk about anything that's
classified and if that's in the
newspaper that's a shame it's incredibly
dangerous when things get out into the
press like that you're not only just
getting a scoop on something you're
playing with people I all right as I
said cNN has not confirmed that Fox
reporting Barbara stars with us at the
Pentagon it would be really interesting
to know when the president retweeted
this what he really had in mind about
this was it something that perhaps he
thought I was not serious enough
seriously classified enough that he
could go out there and retweet it and if
there are some mixing up of the threat
here between these shorter range
missiles and the ballistic missiles
which really is the focus of the threat
right now